[Music]
me and Hannah you can try Singaporean
McDonald's from the very first time we
know what to order so we asked our
friends over here so yeah and again so I
think you should try the nasi lemak
burger this is basically everything
enough cinema is but without the rice oh
that's true I'm gonna show you the
inside which is so beautiful
whoa do you see that scene actually I'm
a little worried ready actually really
good kind of confusing them
it's like slightly sour which I like is
the sauce right what do you call this
awesome a black baby like very Asian
tasting chili is so juicy this doesn't
sing I think the best part of this is
bag cucumber and a burger is weird
though LM XYZ is the best in the region
it is a spiciest oh no we've heard from
our friends over here that the spiciness
can have an impact on your digestive
system in a strong way why do they feel
so substantial here like it kind of
looks like the promotional pictures okay
you guys you guys type this up too much
choice
it's on the spicy my tongue is on fire
really does it get worse yeah it took
like 20 seconds to start doing the spice
yeah it's pretty good has a lot of
flavor I will update you tomorrow on how
powerful this dish was to my system
maybe wait
ice cream break there's a little hack
apparently here in Singapore we're a
delivery do you order ice cream so that
don't deliver to you faster mmm oh that
tastes exactly like the American softer
version there's nothing in the world
like it very unique no I'm serious
today we go for the hot curry sauce ah
that is a color doesn't like curry
it's not bad it's like sweet and sour
mixed with a curry powder and it has a
interesting aftertaste it probably isn't
my sauce of choice oh my god what my
Singapore is it beef and any don't like
berry sauce laughs and we have the
cheesy fries which is new in all menu in
our country I hope it's good
it looks a little wimpy okay let's just
do this
we need fries let me know you got to eat
like ten at a time Oh Oh perfect it's
good some people get I got a hot dog
stand it does taste like a hot dog fries
are the exact same that they are in
America you can't really go wrong when
you have cheese bacon
how could he mess that up I wanna see
what they think we're the first time
this critters right oh do like you would
just get this pot yeah I know what I'm
gonna do the rest
that has nothing I did not know what to
expect I thought it would be the same it
actually was better juicier everything
had a slight Asian flair to it an Asian
Flair in a naturally Asian way hmm
[Music]